right for over a year we have been
reporting accurately and now we know
more about Bruce or suspicious ties
diffusion GPS remember his wife Nellie
or actually worked with Christopher
Steele for fusion GPS and the ones that
put together the Clinton bought and paid
for Russian dirty dossier and as you
know the dossier was a campaign op
research document put together by Steele
himself he doesn't stand by it a former
foreign spy full of Russian lies full of
misinformation full of propaganda
Hillary paid for it the DNC paid for it
all by funneling money through a law
firm to fusion GPS and now according to
John Solomon's reporting tonight we have
clear evidence that Bruce or the fourth
most powerful person in the Obama
Justice Department was working
hand-in-hand with Christopher Steele and
Hillary Clinton's op research team both
before and after the election clearly to
stop presidents from from winning the
election and then after he won the
election literally destroy him with the
Clinton funded Russian lies that nobody
ever verified and has now been totally
debunked now let's take a look at some
of the most damning evidence look at
this July 1st 2016
Christopher Steele reaches out to Bruce
Horry wrote quote there is something
separate I wanted to discuss with you
informally and separately it concerns
our favorite well business tycoon now
that clear reference was to then
candidate President Trump that was
followed up on July 30th 2016 3 months
before election day Steele met Bruce and
Nellie or for breakfast now this was a
meet-up
that was documented by this text quote
great to see you and Nellie this morning
Bruce let's keep in touch on the
substantive issues
Glenn Simpson founder of fusion GPS is
happy to speak to you on this if it
would help now just one day later one
day anti-trump FBI investigator Peter
struck he opened up the investigation
into the phony claims of Trump Russia
collusion do you see how this is all
coming together
and after the election ended and
president Trump was sworn in which they
didn't think what happened well then the
communication even continued now on
January 31st 2017 president now
president just sworn in steel texted or
quote just want to check you are okay
still in the situation and able to help
locally as discussed along with your
bureau colleagues now this text is
actually damning for two reasons one it
shows a Bruce or was in fact feeding the
FBI steals lies misinformation and
propaganda and number two it shows the
FBI was breaking their own protocol
their own rules steel had been barred
from working with the FBI November 2016
because of his leaking to the news media
and let's also keep in mind the major
role that this steel Clinton paid for
dirty dossier played and the FISA
applications against the Trump campaign
associate Carter page we now have proof
Bruce or likely funneled the dossier to
the FBI a document or knew was op
research bought and paid for by the
opposing political party in an election
year and remember just that yesterday on
this program house Intel committee
chairman Devin Nunez he revealed
exculpatory evidence was completely
omitted from the FBI's FISA applications
against Carter page watch this there is
exculpatory evidence that we had that we
have seen of classified documents that
need to be declassified these were not
like SOPA Tory in nature in what ways
I'm gonna press you if scope tutorial
what way in that the Carter page FISA
when those the judges should have been
presented with the six culpa Tory
evidence that the FBI and DOJ had do you
see this there you have it this is
Obama's Justice Department part of
Obama's branch literally using your
federal government your tax dollars in
this case as a weapon against the Trump
campaign
and then later the President of the
United States President Trump himself
they use Clinton campaign material never
verified never corroborated the phony
Russian dossier to rig a FISA Court
application lying to judges to spy on
team Trump then they use the very same
op research that she paid for to open up
a phony Russia collusion investigation
into then candidate Trump and then they
leaked the contents of the dossier to
the press because they wanted to
influence the election in favor of
Hillary Clinton against Donald Trump and
lie to you the American people and on
top of it all the FBI on top of Hillary
paying steel through fusion GPS and the
DNC paying them the FBI paid them the
FBI made 11 payments to Christopher
Steele I have been saying and now it has
all come together the biggest political
corruption abuse of power scandal in our
lifetime this should outrage every
single American I don't care what your
political affiliation is let me say this
slowly they try to steal in the United
States of America a presidential
election and we have the evidence in
other words they abuse their power to
steal an election a presidential
election our Justice Department has been
weaponized for pure partisan political
gain we have so much on this major
development we're going to talk to John
Solomon and Mark meadows in just a
minute but in other news just the latest
example of why so many Americans can't
trust the media they've been missing in
action on that scandal last night we
called them out again for hyping up yet
another fake news story about the 2016
Trump power meeting between Don jr. and
the quote Russian lawyer
oh they met before with fusion GPS
adapter with fusion GPS anyway they
claimed the president finally admitted
to collusion that's what you have now
been hearing for days and days and days
they said there was stunning new
evidence that the Trump Tower meeting
was
political okay it ended up being about
adoption none of this is new zero none
of this is stunning none of this is
collusion we've known for more than a
year that Donald Trump jr. took the
meeting yeah because like everybody else
oh like Adam Schiff and Hillary Clinton
yeah
everybody wants o up research on their
political opponents that didn't stop the
media even though we've known it for
well over a year in the president Senate
from recycling a fake scandal two days
in a row well frankly all weekend take a
look President Trump has made an
about-face and that much-discussed
meeting between his son Don Jr and a
Russian lawyer at Trump Tower back in
June 2016 the president now admitting it
was all about getting information on
Hillary Clinton he is now bluntly
acknowledging that a trump tower meeting
central to the investigation was in fact
about getting dirt on Hillary Clinton
from the Russians
all of a sudden now the president is
confirming bluntly what it was all about
he says there was no no violation of the
law but he he's admitting finally what
it was all about I think we've actually
entered now a very different realm
because we're no longer speculating now
we actually have people essentially
admitting what how is it the people yet
the people being in this case the
president knighted States in word on
Twitter admitting what happened all of
this phony fake feigned moral outrage
over a non-story that the president had
talked about we've reported they all
reported over a year ago that's why we
called them to destroy Trump press
that's why the American people don't
trust you people in the media and by the
way that's why we'll call you fake news
and if you thought the media's bias
couldn't get any worse well think again
in order to bash President Trump he got
fake News CNN conspiracy TV MSNBC
rolling out the longest known sufferer
of Trump derangement syndrome ever there
she is Rosie O'Donnell last night
literally standing in front of the White
House leading a single law protest
against her arch nemesis and naturally
the media was more than happy to give
her a platform
so she could spew all of her hatred on
national TV shocking
take a look he should not be President
and I don't believe that he's a
legitimate president I believe it wasn't
for Russia he never would have won they
actually gave him the election I believe
that firmly and I think a lot of people
do I believe he should be impeached I'm
sickened by Congress that doesn't call
for articles of impeachment when we have
so much evidence of his horrible high
crimes and misdemeanors did they come in
there and make Trump win win every
single exit poll and every person in
America knew for sure that Hillary
Clinton was going to win do you think
that there was anything to do with
Russia or just a real big swirl for
Donald Trump in these specific areas
with the same exact amount of votes that
would need it we're going to stand up at
the polls and let him know and unless he
goes in and has the Russians kind of fix
it like he did last time in 2016 you
know we're gonna see him gone and that's
what I'm waiting and hoping for that
Rosie's hatred for the president is
widespread among all her friends in
Hollywood all the elite last night the
West Hollywood City Council they voted
unanimously they're removing Donald
Trump's star oh how devastating from the
Hollywood Hall of Walk of Fame in part
because of Trump's quote disturbing
treatment of women ok the move is
non-binding however because the West
Hollywood City Council has no authority
over the walk let's take a look at the
Stars not targeted last night by the
West Hollywood City Council there we
have Bill Cosby recently found guilty of
drugging and sexually assaulting a woman
then you have dozens of other similar
allegations levied against Bill Cosby oh
there is Kevin Spacey
oh yeah he's facing tons of accusations
of sexual misconduct for more than ten
people including multiple victims who
were allegedly abused in their early
teens he got Brett Ratner he's been
accused by multiple women of serious
sexual misconduct and assault Jeffrey
Tambor Oliver Stone and many others but
the West Hollywood City Council is
saying their vote has nothing to do with
politics whatsoever and finally tonight
day six of the biggest trial of the
century the 2005 tax case a Paul
Manafort
well it's come to a close but not
without a very tense moment between team
Muller and judge Ellis according to
reports the judge reprimanded a
prosecutor in court and then accused him
of tearing up this would-be Muller's guy
and judge Ellis repeatedly clashing from
day one with members of Muller's legal
team often questioning the relevance of
quote the evidence or so-called evidence
presented in court
meanwhile the prosecution's star witness
Rick Gates he continued his testimony
from the stand nana forts the defense
attorney oh they raised serious
questions about the character of the
star witness including all the instances
he actually let's see embezzled a ton of
money from Paul Manafort the defense
team accused Gates of using the money to
fund a secret life and an affair in
London and despite all of that the odds
are definitely stacked against Paul
Manafort who currently faces a potential
life sentence this is a 2005 case and
remember what the judge said to put the
screws to man afford to make them sing
or compose so they'll get information so
they can get Trump he started with his
lifestyle they talked about oligarchs
then we got the Muller team guy tearing
up in court and the judge ripping him
saying look at me I think the judge
knows what's going on here I think it's
pretty obvious but because rod
Rosenstein z-- mandate was so broad and
this has nothing to do with Russia
nothing nothing to do with collusion
nothing to do with Trump nothing to do
with the election at all well it's going
this is what Muller gives us it was more